école champagne quartier planoise à
besançon
nous sommes ici dans un secteur classé r
est plus un la cloche a sonné première
leçon donc ré plus signifie réseau
d'éducation prioritaire renforcer un
acronyme barbare qui désigne des écoles
de quartiers populaires bénéficiant du
dédoublement de classes en cp l'an passé
en cea cette année pour cette école mais
visiblement cette nouveauté n'est pas
encore totalement assimilés vous savez
ce que ça veut dire les classes
dédoublées
non pas exactement mais je crois que
c'est un instant pour mes enfants savoir
c'est des classes où il ya moins
d'élèves pour qu'ils puissent apprendre
dans de meilleures conditions
c'est bien ça ouais ça va prendre plus
pour les enfants et tout ça va c'est
mieux comme ça c'est comme on a beaucoup
les enfants dans les classes c'est un
peu dur et quoi y'en a pas beaucoup de
les enfants ça va ça va passer les 10 à
15 enfants maximum par classe c'est le
principe du dédoublement à la fin de
l'école primaire 20% des élèves ne
maîtrisent pas les savoirs fondamentaux
lire compter écrire mais un an après sa
mise en place le principe du
dédoublement semble déjà porter ses
fruits
les retours qu'on a su que notamment en
termes de lecture d'apprentissage de la
lecture les progrès sont importants et
que l'on considère qu' il ya un gain de
1 à 2 mois dans l'apprentissage de la
lecture
pour cette rentrée 2010 8 est la franche
comté contre 150 classes dédoublées en
cp et ce1
une centaine de plus que l'an passé